right rolling inside
my insides are coming out
there's no context for that by the way
[Music]
inside
because that is what voice is you know
in a way yeah you know it's The Echoes
of the inside the echo of the inside the
reverberations of your inner shape of
your inside the shape of your insides
wow turn to audio Yeah the shape of your
insides welcome back podcast everybody
episode
176 we have a very wow special episode
for you today because it's just me and
the boys it's just me Jordan now
everyone else has been let go everyone
else has been let go this has taken over
um we went through a forced buyout and
uh this is now the remainder of quarter
digital oops it was very ugly very very
ugly yeah yeah but it's been resolved it
was actually like more of a blood it was
lots of Bloodshed yeah surprising
amounts Chase is strong he is yeah
yep but he's gone now yeah it took it
took three it took all three of us to
take down Daniel yeah Daniel yeah
wolf yeah he lifts a lot of gimbals so I
never realized you wouldn't believe how
strong his forearms are from all those
gimbal lifts pretty tremendous yeah
uh wow so oh my goodness I think my oh
that's learning how to do this no no by
the way we don't cut on anything anymore
so uh if it's janky well just welcome to
it
um so hey
[Laughter]
I was gonna ask him about his hat
uh Jake was wondering about yourself
yeah I don't know what might happen
means either so Matt so matters
I know I'll just preface this for the
for the listener okay Matt in all of
these videos where's this hat that says
22nj on it yeah
and I'd like to know if he even knows
what it means it's like it's like a
brand it's some I don't know probably
designer brand see is it a brand because
well I got it from I got a thrift
situation but you know the Thrift in Los
Angeles is all like hawaii-toity and
it's like more expensive than it should
be for no reason it's like and so like I
just liked the material of the hat but
like the I don't understand I don't know
what it means I get it man you know when
you find a good hat I just stick a nice
comfortable hat you know I like the
texture it is a dangerous game though
yeah you know you wear a shirt like I
used to always wear shirts and I didn't
know what they meant they just fit like
that's my barometer basically for style
yeah and even that I'm not really paying
attention to anymore either but you know
when you're representing something and
you don't know what it means you're in
dangerous territory and that could be
very offensive I uh I I did the same
thing back in the day I used to have a a
state college
hockey shirt or a hockey jersey which is
um
Penn State is State College that's where
it is or it's in Happy Valley but it's
called State College and so I had a I
had this hockey jersey and it and it was
a white hockey jersey with a blue chest
that just said State College and I
thought that was funny because it was
like
it seemed so generic but then I but then
people would come up to me and be like
oh dude are you from PA
they know and yeah and well because
everybody in PA knows what state college
is yeah it's it's Penn State huh um so
yeah I I uh you know I was I thought it
was like you know it said College on it
yeah it's like like a sports sports
shirt or something right that's what I
thought but anyways Matt you're at your
hat as far as I understand it I might be
way off here
it refers to an airport
oh does it okay that's cool well he may
be waiting I can barely hear it
take a minute and get situated good Lord
people I just put Jordan tell your jokes
tell your joke tell my joke yeah tell
your jokes yeah why don't you be funny
don't tell my joke um tell your joke
about the doctor about the what
the doctor oh the doctor well it's not
my I can't really take credit for this
uh but it's depressing so let's get
started
um a man goes to see the doctor
see the doctor doctor I'm suffering from
horrible depression God I can't get out
of bed
what do I do
and he goes well son
the famous comedian
pavilanovsky is in town go see him
and he goes but doctor there's a problem
I am pavlanovsky
that's a reminder that the people who
make you smile make him a smile back
every once in a while and then he turned
to the doctor and said Doctor I can't
believe it I've broken my arm in several
places
and the doctor said well then don't go
to those places
wow that's good is that original or is
that also no that's from a meme yeah
yeah and for those of you who know what
my joke was I panicked on the name I
don't know what it is so I just said
pavlovovski or something I don't even
remember what I said anymore it's Pablo
Boston yeah it doesn't matter yeah yeah
he's a he's a great guy is that all one
word Paula lavaski yeah sounds like one
word it's a one-word name man I think
it's Spanish kind of thing I can hear
you again by the way just just FYI
talk to me more about the history
every every airport in America has like
a a number like that oh okay oh yeah I'm
pretty sure your hat just refers to a
runway in New Jersey okay how cool I am
big on Aviation so yeah that's why I
thought you had it because your dad is
yeah yeah yeah my stepdad is flies
planes and owns one right yeah that's uh
but no that's not the reason the truth
yeah I'm a big poser basically yeah I
love it man you're in L.A dude yeah yeah
22nj airport okay he's gonna get to the
bottom of this okay that's the uh that's
the Our Ladies heliport which is uh out
of uh New Jersey maybe that's literally
where this Hat's from like it's actually
at the airport that's where this
probably is wow I want to trace it back
it traveled all the way here do a 23and
me on the land on my head let's trace
this thing yeah let's trace this all the
way back unless it's like a brand that's
from there or people trying to you know
there's definitely some inside stuff
going on because I also did a little
Googling before this on the 22nj apparel
did you yeah and uh the hat is one of
the first things that comes up okay okay
are there other things other
articles of clothing
just asking for a friend because yeah I
think maybe I just want to be 22 and
Jade out you get a full jump just get
the full that whole situation happening
you know yeah anyway I think the point
is starting at the top work my way down
you're wearing something and you don't
know what it means yeah consideration
sometimes I just don't care oh yeah but
I also I do have this um uh jean jacket
and it's also a thrifted thing because I
like it I like the thrift around here
it's kind of well that's a nice jean
jacket yeah but so the the cool thing
about that jean jacket it has this like
interesting history where it's like
um it's a Marlboro brand jacket
um and but they they stop they I think
it's it's illegal for uh cigarette
companies to sell merchandise now like
they've made it yeah they banned they
used to have Marlboro points or whatever
back in the 90s yeah you could get all
the the swag right so you could Marlboro
jacket was the big swag right you were
incentivized to buy cigarettes so that
you could earn enough points it was
weird that that's a get lung cancer yeah
like I get that part of it but I don't
know as a as an adult like I think you
have the right to yeah earn your
Marlboro bucks on what you'd like yeah
yeah am I crazy imagine that the general
expectation is very low and that's what
we're working with for sure yeah they're
like I don't know guys people might
buy more cigarettes if you give away
that jacket yeah yeah maybe that I don't
know about that one yep well cigarettes
ever be extinct in this country you
think
as long as people are growing and drying
tobacco there will always be some
tobacco to smoke they just kind of
evolve over time you know the dinosaurs
died off yeah we still got you know
Birds another 23andMe that works for her
Ultra cigarettes yeah there you go yeah
I mean I think it's well established at
this point that they're terrible for you
so if there's any question about that I
don't I don't know what to say to that
it does not stop me from buying Captain
Crunch let me tell you yeah
nibble on that no still yeah let's also
limit the size of soft drinks that
people can buy yeah man the Super Size
Me movie ruined everything yeah it
didn't it come on man
for 39 cents you used to be able to
supersize yeah but TLC can run the 19th
season of my 600 pound life can it that
can monetize but God forbid the Ronald
makes a little side side hustle out of
it I want to be able to swim in my
Coca-Cola
this is great God forbid Ronald has a
quote side Hustle
yeah you gotta feed the boy
passionate about this super size was so
fun anyway did you know that they had
they had to like they make uh extended
cup holders for your cars for the big
boys like that they've had them they had
them before like with the big big cups
that you need to like get the extenders
Chevy Suburban Big Mac edition yeah
we'll make our way back to it yeah we'll
get back I hope so we'll find our way
yeah all right well listen there's a lot
of projects going on and I think yeah I
think people deserve uh an answer they
just want to answer it that way people
are asking people deserve answers
what what uh what happened with the with
the Animorphs
what uh yeah I mean I feel like we
followed through on it pretty Faithfully
you know yeah you paid off pretty much
exactly what we were hoping for yeah uh
and you know the people clearly love it
love it you know big fan of the video
and get more views I mean people watched
it really really enjoyed it there's a
lot of really positive comments in there
we we saw in the analytics that it just
wasn't getting served to people yeah you
know as consistently as the other videos
it's just like yeah it's not seemed like
the click-through rate was good and
everyone liked the video a lot and
that's that's the fun thing about the
analytics too is uh you know I saw that
the the actual watch duration was higher
than any of the other videos on the list
that were available yeah so clearly
there's like an appeal for this kind of
weird stuff which just Thrills me I mean
Eric Andre's entering at sixth season
there's an appetite there's enough for
it yeah uh and that makes me happy but
yeah the algorithm I don't know I've
been wondering this Jake what the heck
changed in the algorithm something
changed
uh in the same way that it was before no
I think it's just honestly it's just
shelf life of like certain ideas and
stuff like this is totally normal
for
everything
um like you have Ebbs and flows and
you know things like you have certain
audience and certain that that are
watching certain videos and they come
and go and I mean think about your own
experiences on YouTube
you know are they consistent with the
idea of like finding a channel being
really into that channel and then moving
on from that Channel or moving finding
another Channel and fun fact I've only
ever watched one YouTube video and I
just watched that one it's great yeah
let's just go again this is the one yeah
man you're gonna beat it so yeah yeah I
don't know I mean
that's just consistent with like uh you
know when you break it down into these
industrialized terms but like that's
consistent with
consumption habits of entertainment
content
um you know and so yeah yeah are they
are they transparent with algorithm
changes when they make them do they
announce them or do they just kind of
Twitter they don't unless it's something
that is uh
uh like a new feature
typically they don't or a feature that
like they're really trying to be
forthright about they don't really and
and most of the time you gotta also
remember it like this like
there's the YouTube
uh product team
is like the the guys who are responsible
for
the actual product of YouTube as a you
know a thing to the world
and
um so you know when they make a little
adjustment on say
how influential tags are or what
constitutes a satisfied viewer so that
the video that they just watched should
be served to more viewers you know these
are like they they might make one tweak
you're talking about a platform that
does what uh
how many hours a a minute now
oh I'd rather think of yeah content I
mean it keeps kind of curious though how
many yeah right hours
how many hours are we
pumping in this website
break my brain day
yeah cause we can do some every day 271
000 hours of video content
oh
uploaded uh every day oh my God say
again 270 3.7 million new videos per day
270 000 hours
more than 500 hours every minute
that's just on the one website though
you know you couldn't oh my gosh it's
too much so it's so much I mean it's in
the in servers good Lord server yeah I
want to go there castles yeah
the one on earth they've gone back so
you know they have they have a huge job
to do they have to figure out okay where
did this video come from hmm where is it
being seen because you know they're not
gonna store like videos that are
primarily consumed in say India
over here because that would just create
a bunch of CDN like bandwidth costs that
are totally unnecessary and costly for
them to serve it all the way on the
other side of the world so you know they
have to figure out okay
for example our um primitive technology
videos
those videos
the predominant viewership comes from
India Cambodia Vietnam and Southeast
Asia
um now when we uploaded those videos we
uploaded them from Los Angeles those
videos who knows they might you know
they might still be stored internally on
their servers over here but you know you
also think hey maybe it's more likely
that they move it
um
to somewhere else where it's more local
to the place where it's being consumed
it that's just an example that might not
be exactly the way that is done but
imagine
a hundred thousand of those decisions
having to be thought about and decided
on
like every day by a you know a huge team
of people and so
um yeah that just has an overall effect
of like little things can sometimes have
significant impacts on different
channels but I don't think that's
necessarily the situation with us and
you know we've seen a little bit of a
decline in viewership lately and I think
most of that honestly is just related to
the shelf life of the react show I think
it's interesting predominantly the the
main driving force of it the pre react
show is still you know super popular it
still performs incredibly well but
compared to where it was
two and three years ago it's it's not
doing those kind of numbers
um and that's everything from total
viewership to also new viewership and
new viewership is another big factor
that has always been important on the
platform but is is still just as
important as it's ever been yeah and
that's the amount of new people that
your videos you know when you have this
library of videos out there how many
people do they catch that are new
and that come in to become a fan or a
viewer of your channel well because the
viewership on the react show is like
tremendously high percentage-wise of
people who are already viewers right
um yeah about 75 oh wow or so I mean I
can pull up the real the exact numbers
yeah let's talk numbers numbers but
we're numbers that's what the kids want
do you think they will care about this I
don't know if they do we don't talk
philosophy we talk statistics we talk
statistics I want to see graphs I want
to see charts different colors but I
don't want to see them I want to hear
them on a podcast yeah that's what I'm
really looking for five days there's
numbers and figures explained in details
comparison
your age yeah yeah
that's what I'm hearing it yeah you know
it's good stuff it kind of makes my eyes
glaze
if you guys aren't interested in this I
my favorite part of Statistics is the
long pauses between numbers personally
yeah it's like a Zen it's like a Zen
period absolutely you know yeah this is
the equivalent of like the YouTube
commercials on Youtube tv where it's
like take a Moment of Zen yeah and it's
like just a hummingbird I would say
suspense personally because I can't wait
to hear the numbers
do you want to hear the numbers baby
numbers
baby all right so my beer new viewership
versus
Kylie it keeps
doing this thing more suspense oh boy
I'm here for it
just makes that sweet release even
better you know
I mean what is it like uh yeah it's
about a quarter a quarter viewers
viewers are new viewers
I mean because also like once somebody
comes in for the first time and then
returns to watch one of your videos
within 30 days they're considered a
returning viewer okay so interesting
it's yeah well thank you to all the new
and returning viewers yes hello yeah
hello yeah uh you're probably not
watching this podcast because who knows
maybe maybe we'll have to look at the
numbers you never know well anyways
uh Jordan I want to move on to another
topic yeah talk to me talk to me
do you have any
um uh I guess explaining that you feel
like you need to do
um no I do slightly offensive bowling
alley oh there see oh I don't know do
you always have to explain yourself well
here's the thing Matt I'm curious you've
seen it obviously yeah is it out on
YouTube yet it would be by the time this
releases but yes yeah it will be out
yeah and this won't offend I mean did it
I don't think so no I think I nailed it
yeah I think you nailed it like because
again it's about it's about that line
you gotta you gotta ride it into it it's
a scary game it's a scary line and I I
think you nailed it man thank you man
it's it's like
yeah it was uh
it's a terrifying place to be let me
tell you every single time that we have
done those bowling animation reviews
with everybody no one has seen my
animation and I always have this fat
knot in my stomach yeah because I'm like
is this the end I'm sure is this the
final Final Countdown yeah yeah and uh
the response warmed my heart beyond what
I could say great because yeah you know
you put yourself in a box and again it's
like this this idea of desensitization
like genuinely the first you know
animation that I did I was alone for
three days I made it bad and then I got
used to it so I made it worse and that
was just the first day so the next two
days are just continuing to make it
worse and then when I finally showed
Dean I think Dean was the first one to
saw to see it his response horrified me
because he's like you can't you can't
and that was the first time I woke him
and saw it with new eyes and thought Oh
No but I can't it's too late yeah so
here we are done the whole thing 30
seconds of really just Primal domestic
abuse yeah yeah so it's like a situation
now where with this new one it's you
know I feel like I've honed in on the
line and I feel like the twist ending
with the turkey kind of brought it home
it wasn't just like it's good Mass death
it was yeah it was a lead up to a slight
twist that's why that's why it's funny
because you're contextualizing it within
a bowling yeah yeah it's not just it
being bowling pins and bowling balls
that makes it anyway if you haven't seen
slightly offensive bowling alley
animations yet we highly recommend you
do yourself a favor make it happen do
yourself a favor there's three of them
now because yeah there's three of them
and you know the funny thing about all
three of them is I've been wanting to do
participate in these rolling out
animations and I have not because of
punch for punch every single time it has
always sucked you up and once again
there's a new these bastards over at
Netflix or like you gotta give us more
you gotta give us more we need um so
that's what I've been doing and that's
actually also why I haven't been you
know like we because the last few videos
like I've been in them with you yeah and
but I haven't like actually participated
it's like the feigned participation yeah
this because I've just been on camera
and not like actually like helped like
in attention for the most part look I
mean because of that puncher punch
episode six yeah which is about
extraction to the movie is live
currently oh yeah it would be yeah
and uh the movie's also out yeah so that
one brother yeah the movie has an insane
Warner though the movie is great in
itself but the there's one there's a
Warner that is like 22 something minutes
long and it's actually incredible you
know like it's not it's not like just a
Warner for the sake of having a Warner
it's like actually insane that it goes
this long and and goes all these
different directions well that's the
funny thing too is the extraction one
had a sick Wonder yeah and then they
just came back and they're like oh we
can top that he's easy easy because
every time I kept being amazed Matt was
like yeah
we're just getting started yeah so
recommend that audience are kind of
becoming desensitized to
just what is capable in a movie now hmm
yeah you know the possibilities do seem
endless like imagine if You released
Avengers end game or extraction 2 or you
know some of these like Feats of
cinematic achievement in terms of the
the craft and the professionalism that's
being applied like you might not like
the story okay whatever but like
I'm talking about operating at the
highest levels of taking all the tools
that you have available
and putting them into the same spot at
the same time to create something that
people truly haven't seen before
I feel like audiences are don't even
no that's happening well I mean what
when we first obviously like people do
but like in general yeah you know yeah
overall well when I first saw Avatar
like the first avatar I was working in
the movie theater I managed to like
sneak in and watch a whole viewing of it
and for me three hours all three hours
you were not working for all I wasn't
working I lost that job very very
quickly yeah were you the guy who was
supposed to take the ticket and rip it
in half and put it in yeah I did I'm not
joking there's a there's a theater where
I used to work and I could tell Dude I
could talk about this theater all day
long but I used to whatever job you got
in your shift start is the they wouldn't
rotate it's the only thing you did for
eight solid hours oh and so if you ended
up on the door you were working the door
for eight hours straight and there was
one manager in particular was the bane
of my existence uh who would enforce on
a Tuesday morning when there was nobody
in the studio in the studio in the
theater uh that you have to stand
outside the door not inside the door not
on a stool stand out side
even when it's raining okay so Tuesday
morning comes along it's raining outside
and I have to stand outside in the
pouring rain that's insane uh to take a
ticket from nobody from zero people
because if I well here's the reality if
I was three inches further back everyone
would be running by yeah there'd be no
chance for me to stop them for sure
three inches forward though I could play
100 defense exactly it's like what no
there's no reason yeah so man anyway I
saw it in that theater so at least
there's one good memory and uh at the
end of the movie I was just absolutely
in awe I was like I can't believe this
was feasible I can't believe this was
achieved and I turn around to like take
it in and everyone's already gone and I
realized at that moment I'm like oh
they're just moving on to the next thing
yeah it's the next one because once the
credits roll is like wow right okay okay
what do you want for dinner yeah people
move on so yeah for sure yeah it was
like a real humbling thing it's just a
way to distract yourself for three hours
pretty much that is truly the quandary
of of like traditional movie making
and and and that's the thing is like you
make it and then
people go good job yeah nice and then
and that's it next well that's Jake
that's honestly why genuinely in any
creative Endeavor you don't do it for
the end result you don't do it for the
praise you don't do it for the you do it
to do it you do it for the pleasure of
doing it for creating that's how you
maintain longevity in any creative field
if you're satisfied by the process the
process will always be there for you to
be satisfied by but the praise
disappears in a second and if you don't
get the praise you want or God forbid
expected then the entire thing was a
devastating experience and so yeah for
me it's like well the stuff we put out
here I don't even like the the response
is not what is keeping me going it's
like yeah you know making the anamorphs
like what a treat you know making this
whole you know that rips out of his
underwear like
when we make something and it is and it
is like
you know well received that does help
yeah it does oh I'm not saying it
doesn't feel good yeah it's still I
guess it's just not real good it's you
know the act of creating is really the
driver it's like that's what brings me
peace personally yeah right you know
yeah I know I feel that I feel it for
you and like the rest is is gravy yeah
and it's I feel like the more fun you
have making something the better the
results are anyway so yeah I always
strive for that yeah that makes sense so
was your least favorite job at the movie
theater standing out front in the rain
or was there one that was even worse
than that
it was to to be totally honest when I
first started working I I told my mom
she's like you should do like
videography or you should do something
where you use your brain her exact words
and I said I said Mom I don't want to I
say I use my brain all the time I want
to turn it off and just go to work and
just make money yeah I genuinely felt
that way and the minute that I was in an
environment where I had to turn my brain
off I was like I was so uncomfortable
and devastating I was trying to find
like Optimal ways to change the system a
little bit like maybe we could do this
maybe we could do that and it was always
met with reprimand and like punishment
uh you're laughing too much like it
literally is a critique that I got and
it just felt like it was stifling every
part of me that that wanted to be
creative and it ended up with me just
just quitting I just couldn't but I
couldn't bother with it anymore I
couldn't handle it anymore and uh it's
fair you know the day I quit I still had
all my tickets uh that you can go see
free movies when you work in a movie
theater
and uh the the day that I started
working there they informed me that
someone had stolen from the movie
theater and so all benefits were removed
from everybody including me who clearly
didn't do it I just showed up but for
the entire duration of me working there
I didn't have benefits we got them in
the last month when I the day I
announced that I was going to quit after
two weeks naturally so I saved my movie
ticket after two and at the end of my
last uh session
um the manager I don't remember his name
now but I you know we were on first name
basis with everybody I I walked out and
said goodbye to everybody I said thank
you so much I'm you know see you later I
walk out and then I walk to the front
and I ask for a ticket I think it was
Ninja Assassin or something back then
and it's like I'd like to see Ninja
Assassin and the manager who I just
walked out again first name basis goes
hello sir how may I help you program and
I'm like Mike Mike what are you talking
about he's like uh I just want to use my
ticket and he goes oh I'm sorry tickets
are only for employees and I'm like
we're doing this and I just walked right
by the ticket guy because he's my friend
and I just walk like I'm like I'm
watching Ninja Assassin I've been
waiting all week so I just go in and I
watch it and I walk out but it's like
that kind kind of environment where it's
like you know I remember telling them
that I was going to go pursue
videography and it was met with a scoff
it was met with like a oh well good luck
yeah and it wasn't you know it wasn't
warm encouraging it wasn't creative and
yeah I think that for me was such a
brutal wake up to pursuing what you love
no matter what yeah uh and I'm really
glad I I have that in my back pocket
because that scared me into working real
hard for a real long time and it pays
benefits like if you keep going day in
day out you'll develop a skill set that
you can use to for yourself from that
kind of stuff and yeah I'm really glad I
have that as horrible as it was at the
time it's like yeah I look back on it
fondly because it definitely served a
purpose for me you know hard work
doesn't feel as hard when you actually
enjoy it yeah it's very true and you
actually like it and you're never bored
of it then yeah that hard work gets a
lot easier yeah
um yeah and there is something to be
said for like just having some work
experiences where you just have to grind
yeah
um even if you don't like it um
especially when you're young definitely
I think there's there's an expectation a
lot of times where people think oh well
I you know I want to do this or I got a
degree in this and so I should be able
to do this and it's just not how it
works really you know it like you have
to
you have to grind to figure out
what what is actually worth grinding for
very true
um and at least that was my experience
um and you know I'm glad I did it I
wouldn't I wouldn't want to go back I'd
do it if I had to of course but
um yeah I remember uh I mean like before
Corridor just you know doing a bunch of
like odd jobs and just grinding to just
get a paycheck so I could feed myself
yeah
um yeah those are good memories to have
you know yeah and it's uh youth is also
great for finding your limit you know
like when I was a younger VFX artist I
would just and I was freelance the whole
time so I would just not turn off I
would just go and go and go and there
was one period of time where my house
was under construction like my family's
house who I was living with was totally
under construction the whole thing
flooded the whole house is closed off
only the garage is open and I have my
little computer in the corner of a
garage with a couch in the back they're
not even living there uh I'm supposed to
be living in Pasadena but I'm still
living at the house because I'm working
and I started to keep an hour log for
this particular set of jobs that I took
on it flat rate mind you I was an hourly
devastating decision uh but again lesson
learned and I was keeping an hour log
and for 30 days straight no days off I
averaged 17 and a half hours in front of
the computer a day oh oh my God I would
work for 17 and a half hours and I would
sleep on the couch and I would play
three games of Rocket league and then
I'd start work again and I did that for
30 days and my mental health just went
yeah like it's never done before yeah
and I found myself in a really weird
spot and yeah I managed to to get out of
it at the end of the day you get really
good you would have never learned that
really you know
and I'm really gonna cry yeah Power comp
together maybe sometimes yeah but she
would have never you know you would have
never known that limit about yourself
yeah you not had experienced that yeah
so when I was feeling a little one time
but yeah I always have the memory of
like how far I could now it wasn't
healthy and it wasn't a smart idea yeah
but I know where I can take it if I need
to like I've been there uh and that I
couldn't do that now I'm really glad I
did it when I was young because I always
had that that frame of reference true
yeah well you also know that you
shouldn't do that no no you yeah there's
a reason to have to do that you know
there shouldn't it's somewhat acceptable
when you're like a 20 to 25 year old and
you know and it's like okay that's he's
just you know he's doing his thing yeah
certainly yeah you've done it 10 years
20 years after it it's it's uh you know
people who love you should should talk
to you yeah yeah I mean in the visual
effects world too you hear all the
horror stories of overtime and it's it's
like at the end of the day if I'd done
that but I went to my bank account and I
went look at this that'd be one thing
but I made I think I made a dollar an
hour oh it was flat rate it was like I
would have been so much better anywhere
else yeah uh but you know less than a
second yeah good well we all do those
jobs that aren't worth it exactly yeah
it's exactly yeah because I've never
done I didn't have the movie like The
Grind job that was like because I was
always a filmmaker but I definitely had
some really like bad I've talked about
it on the podcast
this is the diddler yeah yeah there's
like working yourself real hard and then
getting dead all day yeah you know
apples and oranges
I'll do a few months of the movie
theater yeah so you know those
experiences even if it is
just in the film world it is still you
can still get some really crap jobs you
know and stuff that like really uh helps
the whole experience I do I do kind of
wish that your experience happened on
the roof right just for the diddler on
the roof like diddler on the roof so
great you know Silver Lining situation
but that didn't happen so really didn't
it didn't it would be a very specific
situation a form of a bronze lining for
that yeah for those of you who are
unaware I'll give a very top level
summary yeah Matt had the unfortunate
experience of having to work for a woman
who was basically attempting to
um pass make passes on you sexual passes
on you yeah and was basically trying to
withhold money and work and things of
that nature that's correct should you
not uh heed her advances that's right
yeah and she was like a middle-aged you
know woman you know yeah
um which in in under no circumstances is
acceptable it's not none yeah by the way
yeah yeah yeah she has a very firm
handshake and Matt has never shaken her
hands
yeah
you have experience with testicles I did
oh yes yes various types yeah yeah
you've really gotten in there there's
yeah there's a video yourself a grouper
maybe in some way I am not I'm not using
my 3D model to do anything to that three
model you know no I am I am hands off
here whatever you say uh no we're
working on a video right now
where we're basically testing the 10
South strength of various types of
underwear to test if the Hulk really
could find anything on the market that
could contain his expansion but here's
the thing here's the thing okay we've
all we've all seen the Hulk yep he hulks
out he hulks out he helps out and what
is he still wearing his pants his pants
Preposterous it is absolutely
Preposterous yeah
so what are these things made out of
this is what this video is about exactly
so we're we're testing the things that
are readily available on the market we
know with MCU Hulk at least at the very
minimum that he is getting his stuff
from stores we know that he has nothing
specially made so we're testing the
expansion from a Ruffalo to what we're
calling a buffalo the expansion from
Ruffalo to Hulk okay
and and we're seeing if anything could
handle that kind of expansion again that
is that is available in the market and
we're doing that in a couple ways you
know we're doing some real world tests
uh finding out how far those stretch
taking that into Houdini and emulating
how far they stretch before they tear
and then throwing them on a Model that
expands and you know it's really
groundbreaking work yeah
do your first tests of material yet oh
we had tremendous success yeah we had
tremendous success phase one of our
testing was an absolute failure uh we
built a little Jack system with fake
Hulk thighs I thought that would be very
fun and exciting and it ended up being a
total dud uh but we evolved yeah of all
the scientists Thunder was more of a
blunder you know that's good yeah that's
good blender thighs yeah
um yeah so the Jack didn't work it
didn't go far enough out which is the
issue yeah so we needed something that
could really stretch those things and
pull yeah to uh completion yeah also how
did you measure that while you were
stretching it a genius idea really
honestly was it Daniel's idea it was
Daniel's idea okay that's why it's a
genius idea
no but Daniel came with a great idea
where he's like hey why don't we lay a
measuring tape out in a plate fly it out
then do the test in the exact same spot
and then we overlay the two and then we
have the distance so we know the
measuring tape is exactly four feet we
can you know if we can't see the numbers
which I think we can based on the lens
I'm not sure but even if we can't we can
estimate based on that forefoot length
and find the exact length where these
things tear because again just tearing
something like vertically just across
from each other is very different than a
radial expansion and the radial
expansion is what we're going to be
doing in Houdini using the numbers that
we get from essentially the linear
expansion rip of the inner pants in real
life so it's real meets uh meets CGI
science experiment yeah exactly just to
get to the bottom of this you know it's
real science people need to know did you
end up getting like some of those Kevlar
motorcycle pants or we got denim you got
denim we got denim for them never nudes
out there you know who you are never
nude yep denim chickens of the world
so yeah we tested Hulk does end up in
denim sometimes yeah yeah he looks great
in denim so we we got denim we got uh
cotton and we got
um
what is it uh spandex spandex yeah
so yeah yeah we're running through the
through all of it yeah I'm proud of what
I'm seeing behind my back whenever I
turn around I see uh a lot it's a very
difficult situation I'm in Jake because
you know
the reality is if we're going to take
the sign seriously we need to be
anatomically correct right and you know
that falls on me that falls on me and
that means that I've you know had a
screen full of all sorts of things right
a few days now it's pretty detailed I
forget it's even honestly any wacky
ideas that we should probably work the
Kings out before you actually go forward
with them
uh in what respect
wacky wacky Jordan ideas about
anatomically correct Hulk that maybe we
should just
mixes go too far yeah you're gonna be
blurred that's for sure it'll most
certainly be blurred and he spent way
too much time on something that will
certainly never be seen yeah but that's
you know Common trend for you for me I
know it's there yeah and I think that's
enough uh to make the science make sense
you know uh yeah it's about doing the
Dirty Work American service jobs you
know it's a dirty job someone's got it
he's got to do it there's no Hulk model
that is anatomically correct so last
time we made we made the most the
highest Fidelity uh Steven Seagal model
in the market and now we have the most
anatomically correct Hulk on the market
the corridor asset collection is growing
rapidly growing with the most valuable
assets on the market and maybe one day
we'll make a quarter action pack I don't
know maybe it depends maybe of just
scientifically fiction accurate
anatomically correct action figures
[Laughter]
animal hybrids in there too yeah we were
talking about doing the uh the anamorphs
uh Transformations as like a corridor
kind of farm pack
you can get all your animals you know
what I mean yeah Corridor collection
yeah we've got a koala now we've got a
shrimp we've got horses yes um
[Music]
I don't think manatees are great farm
animals cows of the sea honestly they're
pretty good you tie a bucket of water
they're snout and they'll live for a
couple weeks yeah yeah interesting I
have a question about cows
a Cattleman
you have a couple of heifers I have a
couple of head of cow but I don't know
if I'd consider myself a cat the fact
that you said head of cows
we're calling them butter Udders over
here butter Udders yeah
cream bags
uh my question is this okay okay shoot
we ride horses we ride donkeys yeah why
don't we ride cows why did the cows
never become rideable are they too are
they not smart enough do they have weak
spines do they yeah do they not submit
to Human
the short answer is that that's not true
people do ride cows really I know
they're right holes not not for not for
practical purposes really but um
people have ridden cows there's there's
pictures of you know cowboys with
saddles on cows sitting on cows well is
that where no cowboys because they ride
horses and they heard angle cow yeah
that's why they're called
but then of course people do obviously
ride bulls not for very long you know
eight seconds is yeah right yeah we all
know about the bull riding but I mean
more for yeah like riding like dealing
from one point
the travel yeah you know practical
purposes well second answer is
well so I was thinking about this the
other day you know the phrase
man is a dog is a band's best friend
well that that I I've really come to be
more understanding of why this phrase is
the more animals that I've gotten
because
animals can be extremely difficult to
work with
it's true especially when you're trying
to produce them or Farm them or do
something that's beyond just like
keeping them as a pet
um
and so a dog
is like one of the most reliable animals
on a farm
you can trust it you can pet it it
listens to commands it you can do things
with it like work work cow or work other
animals with it herd sheep all these
kinds of things I mean it's truly like
having another hand
there's a phrase in ranching like uh if
you have a friendly horse or a friendly
dog or even a friendly cow you might say
oh yeah she's a hand as in uh that thing
is as as as good as another person with
hands out there doing the work
interesting or with hand really okay
yeah there's also another phrase that
one one good dog on the ground is worth
three in the saddle
on the ground
than three bad ranchers yeah yeah that
makes way more sense okay yeah totally
totally so so anyway why wouldn't you
ride a cow the basic question yeah well
first of all a cow specifically is a
calf producing
head of cattle that that is specifically
their purpose is to breed more calves so
that you have more meat product right
um and so first of all you'd be
stressing the animal quite a bit and to
be right riding it around all the time
that you could you can get them docile
enough to ride
um so that'd be the main reason but then
the second reason is like well cows
aren't bred to move you know like
biologically they're not bred to move
like horses can I mean yeah cows are
bovine like roaming
prey animals that you know live on
prairies and things like that but
they're not going to move and listen
like a horse would so you'd just be
working against yourself like it doesn't
it wouldn't
it would it would be like
yeah it'd just be practically ridiculous
right right but see you're saying like
the cows have been bred obviously to not
be ridden and more for you know it's
meat and well yeah for sure if somebody
was super interested but you know before
or before it was a breeding thing when
they were just wild animals yeah you
know I I'm assuming they probably would
have been you could the humans kind of
steered it in One Direction or the other
steer couch that's good cow jokes too
but yeah I guess so like we just decided
horses we ride yeah cows we eat
I mean yeah and people do eat horses too
I mean the Mongols were famous for
basically getting their entire life sub
sustenance from the horse oh wow
interesting okay
um yeah I mean they would do everything
from you know get thread for from the
horse's hair
um to you know horse hide for their
clothes
um
to uh meat to eat and everything else in
between
okay well have you thoroughly answered
my question yeah that's you yeah that
makes a lot of sense you've done it yeah
it's amazing exactly what I wanted I'm
wondering why you know if you ride a
horse or a cow rather you said you get
stressed get stressed just give it a
calf massage
yeah all right I will give you guys each
10 whole dollars if you can tell me the
difference between a heifer a cow a
steer and a bull oh [__]
pepper cow okay a heifer a heifer a
heffa weissen there was a wise myself
called and a cash chicken
start with an easy one what's this
what's a calf a calf is obviously a baby
cow easy we know that's worth two bucks
I'll send you my memo
um a heifer would would it potentially
be like a teenage cow
you're fishing kind of yeah and I like
it
a kind big one kind of
heifer
heffa
I want to look it up out of the corner
of my eye but I'm a better man than that
you're a better man so you said kind of
so that's I'm not yes so I'm Cur correct
correct kind of correct a heifer a
heifer is a female cow is a female
cattle teen who has not had a calf oh I
see oh it's like a so do you call that
an unproven an unproven animal you gotta
prove yourself because again the per the
purpose is you know primarily if you're
raising beef rather than Dairy the
purpose is produced okay
cow until it's given birth so yes
and becomes a mom yeah wow that's so
rude can you imagine saying you're not a
real woman until you give them birth
yeah can you imagine and then you call
your mother a cow yeah heifer in the
meantime yeah
maybe we need to change the trains huh
change the language a little bit Jake
hey look I'm just 2023 I don't feel like
how it's set up yeah
there's nothing we can do about that no
change here
um okay so uh uh then yeah obviously
virgin that's really good out of all the
causes we could do let's redefine the
words we use for for meat production
it's important man they're paying
attention right cows have self-esteem
too I think yeah possible people too
um okay all right all right here is a
unproven male cow Bowl
bull is the Emperor America no no no
is it fixed is a fixed male oh
Castro castrated castrated as a steer
yeah well interesting that there's a
separate word for that a steer versus a
bowl Bowl's got the balls but was intact
grab the bowl by the balls as they say
hey dude yeah
because yeah it's useful though you
might think about it you might think
about it as kind of an ambiguous
reference like why a heifer and a calf
and why a steer in a bowl but it's
actually very useful when you're talking
about
um herd production because you need to
know like hey if I put this bull in with
this head of cattle like first of all is
it related to any of them are you know
are there are there heifers in here are
there cows in here are there steers in
here like are there other Bulls in here
that they're gonna fight with because
again they're not like us like you put
them into a pen together and they'll
just start like fighting until they
establish a pecking order and and tell
you know like there's their little their
little Society is sort of figured out
wow so it's really useful when you're
talking about actually understanding
like the nuances of okay this is a you
know this is we want this bull to breed
with this cow or we're going to bring in
a heifer and introduce it here or these
are you know steers that are going to go
to the butcher or what or whatever
um okay there's all kinds of like useful
rationales for that but it does sound
ambiguous
at the at the onset it did raise an
interesting question though
is incest an issue
ancestral cows incest in the animal
kingdom is absolutely an issue that you
need wow especially in animal production
you have to be very careful of that
because they get like weird
well yeah just like any other just like
anything it's still getting weird how do
you measure who's like who's daddy I bet
they number them you know that's what
your tags are for yeah that's why when
when you have a calf you you tag it
right away I see you know who's it's my
you know who its mom is and then of
course if you've done your if you've
done your leading up to that right then
you should also know who his father is
you see gotcha wow there you go well you
can maintain you can maintain good good
lineage and good stock I see well wow
shame on them wow are there any animals
that have self-respect and don't do that
kind of thing yeah like chickens uh
there's probably like no chickens
there's nothing going on like one of the
dirtiest animals chickens are one of the
dirtiest like do not give an f animals
the whole of the animal kingdom if you
think pigs are bad you think more than
yeah
chickens are right there next to them
they'll eat anything they'll see them in
a mouth yeah they fight all the time the
the rooster's job is to basically do two
things okay go around and make sure that
there's no Predators or other roosters
and
effectively
forcefully you know do the need with all
the hens eggs are filled I get it
and and so yeah you have to be careful
about what you feed chickens we don't
feed our chickens any chicken
or egg nuggets of any kind
um because I just don't think that
that's like it's kind of weird huh it's
kind of weird people some people do it
some people say yeah it's fine it's not
for me yeah
um but yeah chickens are not an
exception maybe there's some maybe
chimpanzees or bonobos you know like
these other high primates might have
a bit more of a like social structure I
don't know we'd have to ask uh Jane
Goodall
huh crows mourn their dead whoa yeah
well so do elephants and dolphins and
yeah yeah yeah but like crows being
small very small brain creatures you
know they're very intelligent wow and
they like they'll have like they'll all
be there's video of this too of them
like huddling around a dead body of a
crow
sticks and stuff and crying yeah
actually real tears that's crazy yeah
yeah
it sounds like a crow cheers like a
really good metal band dude
tears of the crow tears yeah I like that
we'll try that out
um yeah but Bigfoot Barry they're dead
Bigfoot do too yeah yeah yeah
bury the dead yeah that's the thing yeah
I heard a genuine passionate debate
where he's like well why have we never
found him and he's like duh they bury
their dead like
they hold ceremonies and they bury them
dinosaurs
check the feet
you know dinosaurs didn't exist because
they were buried in the ground man no
one's ever found them oh wait yeah
oh wait yeah no it's I don't know it
made me laugh I was like I just I love
the idea of them like just being Beasts
of the forest and then just like taking
time to like dig a grave and say a
prayer oh yeah for sure yeah lay it to
rest yeah and then run off again just
like get out of there stomp around and
throw away your hands humans aren't
really that much different than uh like
the rest of the animal kingdom we're
just more so yeah there's a lot more of
us our emotions are more so I mean I
mean obviously like you know you think
about a technology like this where you
know we're communicating
in this fashion and then we're posting
it for other people to watch and and
that's crazy but like that's like way
Advanced way advanced technology but
emotionally
we're just like more so
and I don't think there's any like
bright line where all of a sudden you
know you cross it emotionally to have
like a uh you know a depth of emotional
understanding yeah I think it's just it
manifests itself increasingly
our idea of Consciousness is like you
know it's not necessarily like uh
specific to human beings uh I highly
doubt it yeah
um yeah yeah
an octopus yeah octopi octopi yeah
octopi very very intelligent sorry
occupy I had a is that really how you
say it do you really say octopi somebody
does yeah yeah I think I think that's it
yeah that's it go say the octopi I had a
I had a really interesting I mean I was
16 at the time I was in physics or
something in high school
and the teacher asked a question and he
said what is it that set Man Apart from
the Animal Kingdom
and I raised my hand thinking I knew
what I was talking about and I said you
know our prefrontal cortex right our
thinking brain right right and he said
no
the fact that we can throw things
and I thought no these bad boys right
here yep thumbs but monkeys have thumbs
and they buy feudalism yeah but monkeys
have thumbs and true yeah you know and
they're like they're they're struggling
man yeah
I don't know I mean they're a little
behind yeah you got some catching
outside come on what are y'all doing
they're making tools now though they are
yeah I'm not talking about my butt
because I saw an article in Paris now oh
yeah they've just developed tools
they've developed their first country
yeah no but they they did discover like
a bunch of little very very simple tools
that monkeys have made and it's like
open nuts and stuff it's very cool like
yeah I think they've always done that
probably like I don't know I don't well
I don't know I haven't been around that
long there's like there's the grass to
get into the ant hills it wasn't like
that it was like open things it was like
things put together to be a thing oh
yeah it was like that no like a no it's
not like a rock okay like oh we hit a
thing with a rock a genius you same
might have like a like a monkey Steve
Jobs in our Miss just inventing things
for the other monkeys like here's this
one monkey in a black turtleneck this
somewhere in the forest introducing the
stick Rock and they're like
it costs 1700 peanuts
I don't know yeah maybe one day maybe
one day Something's Gonna Catch up
that'd be fun huh yeah I don't know if
we'd want that it's kind of fun though
it's elephants suddenly have thumbs up
and suddenly you're like right though
like one of them like when I'm waiting
for the next animal that's a big animals
you know how truly
vicious the and maybe not vicious is in
the right world because it implies evil
but a truly Indus indiscriminate the
animal kingdom is yeah like it's just
it's completely indiscriminate this I've
had this conversation Jake with Adrian
she loves bears and I say Bears will eat
you from the stomach out yeah right
without caring at all yeah no and you
want to hug them they enjoy it they just
they just oh it's a noise that you're
making that's fun let's continue yep
yeah maybe no thought yeah and a lot of
a lot of predators will go right for the
jugular right try to kill them quick
yeah that's at least like a bit more
friendly yeah for sure well yeah yeah as
friendly as well
they say that's where the saber-toothed
tigers fangs came from oh yeah okay they
could wrap around the neck of a primate
or other animal
it's always fascinating seeing prey get
caught though because they just go stiff
would we do that
I mean yeah have you ever seen people no
way you ever seen them people die I mean
I've seen I've seen people die guys no I
I don't like watch it you ever bet on
Reddit uh yeah there's some stuff there
I've tried like all through high school
there were all those videos of like oh
did you see this one did you see this
one like the Pain Olympics and stuff
like that I gotta say I'm kind of a
person that watches that stuff yeah oh
man I am a little bit a little bit man
honestly like maybe not like the deaf
death videos but like car accident
videos I'll watch that stuff all day
really the idiots and cars subreddit
getting coffee but yeah idiots and Cars
getting caught dying from coffee
uh the the reason being though is more
of a practical thing where it's like
honestly like when I'm driving after
watching because I've been like
following a subreddit for a couple years
now and just watching these videos like
I'm a lot more aware of certain
situations that I'm in where I'm like
looking out for stuff because I know
that people can be stupid like this like
people can do this stuff I guess that's
true yeah so you like you're like more
aware of situations that could happen
when I wrote motorcycles yeah yeah I
think motorcycle accident videos a lot
of scenarios that I wouldn't have
otherwise been aware of yeah you can at
least be prepared for some stuff yeah
that you otherwise wouldn't if you
didn't watch it so that's how I justify
watching tragic stuff for my pleasure no
I went to the Museum of death oh yeah in
Los Angeles what is that what is it
sorry did you have a question for Matt I
got to ask Matt a question about that
okay do you do you actually derive
pleasure from these videos because I
think I should talk I think I must in
some way maybe it's not pleasure that's
maybe a little too far but like it's
it's interesting to me to more of that
because the thing is like I didn't
realize I was benefiting from it when I
first watched it yeah you know what I
mean I after driving and watching it
simultaneously is when I realized that
will not sign up now it's like driving
and watching the first thing you
shouldn't do yeah okay yeah uh
I didn't learn my lesson there they
don't have any of those oh wow no so
like yeah I guess how I got into it
originally was not me going like well I
could learn something you know I'm
assuming there's just a Fascination you
know with that kind of I get that world
I get that it's it's morbidly I'm
morbidly curious too to a certain morbid
Fascination well we'll check in with you
on that every now and then yes update
update so yeah we'll see what that deal
is yeah
but I went to the Museum of death in Los
Angeles and I cannot stress this enough
do not go do not go I thought it'd be
like this is gonna sound insane I
thought it'd be fun I went with a person
who was like very into that stuff but it
was like oh I want to see Serial Killer
letters oh like that's interesting yeah
a lot of that is serial killer stem from
prison it's like what goes on in their
mind yeah yeah stuff like that yeah you
go into room one it's all that it's like
whoa this is like correspondence from
crazy people this is what you know what
were they thinking you on the next room
like the craziest thing is there's an uh
a jumpsuit that someone wore in an
electric chair during an execution it's
like uh it's kind of that's kind of
morbid yeah
um and then you go into the third room
and good Lord it just goes off a cliff
it the walls it's a private collection
the walls are are covered in personal
photographs that have been collected
over the years of just dead no it's Jake
it was off why is this open to the boys
everything like I'll keep it very I know
I'm sorry too I'll keep it very surface
level
I I walk into the room I turn on my left
and there is someone holding a head oh a
couple people went ahead it's a
collection of pictures of this head it
looked like a prop I read the about it
because I was like what is going on I
was in shock and the about it was it was
yeah they took photos of this act and
then they went to an uh an hour photo
development place and then people looked
at it and went well we're calling the
cops yeah and then they went to prison
for life but they spent three days with
this thing took it to a place to get it
developed they didn't take not the head
no no
in the womb right earlier yeah yeah with
the body attached exactly hopefully yeah
it started alive okay but they took the
photos
honestly genius uh but all of it was
like that level of deplorable where it
just made me feel sick and we both
looked at each other we're like let's go
so we like get out of there it's
corridors and corridors of just oh
horrible stuff and we're just like
blinders on trying to get out on it yeah
and we go out the final door and it's
this it's a movie I don't remember what
it's called but it's on a projector
screen and it's just videos of people
dying and there is a popcorn machine
there's a whole series of those movies
called uh what like encounters with
death or something like I don't know but
it was like heavy death metal and just
yeah montages of people dying little on
the nose and there was like it was yeah
come on guys be creative yeah uh but
there was a silhouette of just two
people just eating popcorn in front of
the screen and I was like let's get
let's get
that stuff never really appealed to me
like everything from that to horror
movies I like well yeah I guess there
could be a fascination with it but at
some point you would probably want to
ask yourself hey yeah what's going on
here why am I doing I feel you on that
yeah because you do get desensitized
like yeah for sure the more you're
exposed to it the more you can handle it
and yeah I don't know I I never want and
that's and that's not the same as like
humane
taking of life for the purpose of giving
life either right these are not the same
things you're talking about human
sacrifice
we're talking about animals previously
sorry oh it's about animals
yeah okay sorry okay I mean in the
comments
your you know your
hunting for food you know or and or
you're growing an animal and then that
animal's feeding you like these are
these are completely different things
there's a there's a there's a way that
death can be death is part of life you
can't have life without death right you
can't have death without your life
they're part of the same thing but
there's a yeah I just that to me is just
so
I don't know I just never piqued my
interest I guess yeah I totally get it I
mean I I saw one video of an anaconda
being like cut open because a data
person
it looks like a normal person being
pulled out and then he just turns to
soup yeah and I I couldn't I couldn't
get I still feel yeah it was messed up
yeah I was done man yep and then I
followed that subreddit you did okay no
I'm kidding
that's what I mean though about the
indiscriminate nature of yeah the animal
kingdom it'll just put him down yeah
it's hardcore real hardcore yeah man I
don't play with that but yeah to your
point like killing an animal and I feel
like if you it's something that I it's
so hypocritical of me and I know this
that I feel like I couldn't kill an
animal but I eat meat and I think that's
such a weird disconnect that I have yeah
because I feel like the people who do
that who hunt and who store the meat
appreciate it more and make it last
longer yeah
um so it's a real it's a it's a weird
like ideology that I don't know where I
picked it up or if it's just like uh
well it's just it's a familiarization
thing yeah I just don't see where it's
coming from it's at the grocery store
I'm not I'm full I throw the rest of it
there's like that often gets ragged on
there's nothing really wrong there's
nothing wrong with that like people got
stuff to do they got lives to to live
they've got other important things of
value that they're working on creating
for other people that you know like that
part of the cycle of their day-to-day
just isn't something where that's going
to be their focus because they're
working on something else and without
them having the ability to do that and
go work on something else you know what
things wouldn't we have now so that's
the way that I think about it um but I
yeah people often rag on that and I
don't think
it's it's as critical of a thing as
people make it out to be yeah yeah
do you hunt your own mind
that was almost a sentence I'm gonna
start that over do you hunt your own
meat yeah since I've moved out here I've
started to again and we used to do that
in Minnesota when I grew up and I got
back into mostly white-tailed deer
there's also access deer and other and
other animals out here but yeah
it's good to me yeah and they're
overpopulated so yeah well there you go
yeah
yeah I've always wanted to try like
that fresh Wild game meat yeah it can be
good yeah and there's a there's a if you
take it to the right processor like you
know oftentimes like we took a bunch of
ours and we did um fajita meat with it
and uh hamburgers where they mixed in
like seasoning and ham and all these
other things it's not super it's really
good would it survive the drive
from Texas to Los Angeles
[Music]
next time I drive out and next time I
drive out I'll bring some oh my gosh
that's a meeting for the ages yeah I
have some moose that my friend gave me
and I have some Buffalo as well
and some Elves yeah yeah yeah bring some
kbbq yeah
I have um I have a kbbq yeah thing I
know actually so I could bring it to the
studio and we could cook it up right on
the spot cook it up right on the spot
yep are we doing this meeting of the
ages yeah oh we're doing this next time
next time I drive out I'll bring I'll
bring a freezer that's right oh my gosh
because we know where it comes from
exactly yeah yeah so there's one time
where I did have uh like I guess wild
meat it was jerky uh and it was deer
deer jerky I think or something like
that at a friend's house and I ate it I
was like this is so good and she's like
oh I'm so glad you like it would you
like to meet him I'm like what and she
walks me into her living room and he's
on the wall I'm not joking I was maybe
15 or 16 I was a very soft spirit and
she goes into the next room and I swear
I walked up to it I said I'm so sorry
just the two of us I just needed him to
know like I didn't know you were there
like that's so uncomfortable meet him
yeah meet him yeah I thought you were
about to say it was like alive but I had
Cuts Like sections
they're still processing is harvesting
yes the harvesting yeah oh wow this was
uh this was an interesting one boys
yeah we got in there into everything
from Hulk's underwear to you know air
strips in New Jersey to cows and uh dude
yeah museums of death so I feel like
this was really well-rounded yeah
something for everybody I just want to
thank you guys once again for this you
know man thank you Jake what a joy thank
you for your cow facts yeah anytime show
me the cow facts
joke from the commercials what if we
started a website that gave you all the
like
test results and genetics on cows
yeah it's 23andMe for cows for breeders
huge business and it's called cow facts
about facts 23 and moo you start it and
then we'll catch up
and then yeah website will be called
23andMe 23 and move I I said it too but
he said it louder so he said it louder
Matt said it but you said it louder it
doesn't matter history will forget
all right 23 I want a percentage of the
profits wow it's based on the title
it plays out
it's just Mosey on out
it's trying to also do a casting I like
that it's always really quiet for us so
we just kind of have to it's almost
silent
guys it's almost silent
we're just basically talking
thanks for watching Everybody thanks